hello we begin in Gaza we're Palestinian
factions have launched their largest
barrage of rockets on Thursday one
person has reportedly died in a strike
in rehabot this comes as Israel
continues to Target senior members of
the Islamic Jihad armed group we have
Villa marks to joining us from ask a law
near the border with Gaza and Evelyn we
are getting these reports that one is
really civilian has been killed close to
Tel Aviv but I know you're joining us
from ascalon and that is where the
Rockets sometimes land and Sirens are
heard tell us what's happening right now
yeah during the last 30 minutes or so
there was some intense barrages of
rockets mostly heading north from Gaza
just behind us we heard sirens in this
immediate area they've been heard in
other nearby towns and communities we
had some shrapnel come down just a short
distance away from here seemingly from
one of the intercepted Rockets where the
Israeli defense mechanism known as the
Iron Dome seems to have intercepted one
of those Rockets another much larger
projectile came down very close to the
main road a few hundred yards away from
here and clearly as we saw some of the
rocket launchers go up you could see
that some of them were going on a far
more steep Ascent indicating there were
further range than some of the ones
around here which you know we're a few
kilometers away from Gaza it may well be
that one of those longer range Rockets
one of those projectiles has reached
much closer to Tel Aviv Israeli media is
reporting there have been several
injuries and one death in the suburbs
south of Tel Aviv known as rehabots and
clearly people here now taking shelter
because of that intense barrage over the
last half an hour during all right thank
thank you for the marks thank you so
much for that update from Ashley
meanwhile Israeli airstrikes in Gaza
have killed the fifth senior leader of
the Islamic Jihad armed group four
people were injured in the attack that
took the life of Ahmad Abu Dhaka 28
Palestinians have been killed since the
strikes began on Tuesday at reports from
Gaza
hundreds of mourners attend the funeral
of Islamic Jihad Commander Ali Hassan
rally and his brother Muhammad in Khan
units
they were killed in an Israeli airstrike
in Gaza on Wednesday night
Khali was a member of the Armed group's
military Council and head of alcott's
brigade's Rocket unit
here's one of several leaders killed in
what Israel says is a targeted campaign
against Islamic Jihad
but Palestinians say most of the victims
have been women and children
this apartment Block in high munis is
one of several buildings hit on
Wednesday night
I saw a bright flash of light turning
the Dark Knight into day and then I
heard two explosions within a few
seconds it became Dusty hazy we couldn't
see anything in the house rocks and
glass fell on us I could hear the
children yelling and screaming
several families with young children
live here
we were asleep we heard shelling a loud
noise my father told me to stay inside
and he went to see what happened we saw
debris and shrapnel and destroyed houses
United Nations Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez says the killing of civilians
in Gaza is unacceptable and has urged
Israel to abide by international law he
has also condemned the indiscriminate
firing of rockets into Israel
[Applause]
more families more in their dead Egypt
is leading negotiations to end the
fighting which is the worst it's been in
month
you may see it Al Jazeera Gaza
correspondent Muhammad is in West
Jerusalem with more on where things
stand with a possible ceasefire
it's a complicated scenario as far as
what's going on behind the scenes when
it comes to the prospect of a ceasefire
right now there have been rocket
launches there have been uh from Gaza
there have been airstrikes on Gaza uh it
seems that at the moment we are in the
midst of an escalation but we also know
that there have been intensive
negotiations going on behind the scenes
to try to get to a ceasefire we know
that the Egyptians are mediating we know
from statements that have been made by
senior Israeli officials to local media
Outlets that these officials would like
to see a ceasefire come into effect at
the moment it looks like it's more
complicated than it was a few hours ago
there are some sticking points to
discuss which is making this more
complicated Islamic Jihad for one is
demanding that if there is to be a
ceasefire Israel must commit to not
assassinate any more of their leaders
this is something that Israel says they
are not going to do we've seen five of
their leaders of the over the course of
the past two days assassinated by Israel
and they're saying they have the right
to do that that's one complicating
factor it's going to be crucial to see
what happens in the hours ahead
conventional wisdom behind the scenes is
that everybody wants a ceasefire right
now that seems to be farther away than
it was a few hours ago but there's still
intense dialogue going on
Al Jazeera is set to Premiere a
documentary on dozens of children killed
when Israel bombed Gaza two years ago it
includes personal accounts from families
and home video footage 11 days in May is
produced by award-winning filmmakers
Muhammad sawaf and Michael winterbottom
here's a preview
just after six o'clock there was an
attack in Beijing
a haycot was passing the house of the
al-masri family
four of their children were killed
um
[Music]
Allah
well you can watch the full documentary
11 days in May on Thursday at 20 hundred
hours GMT